hey 42 here if you're traveling in the
vast wilderness of British Columbia
along the wild Alaskan border you'll
come across a gigantic and most
impressive fjords in the middle of
nowhere at the very tip of that field
you'll find a seemingly beautiful quaint
little town called KITT CIL's hundreds
of miles from anywhere you look over at
the remote town nestled within the
beautiful surrounds and you observe that
all the lights are on windows emit a
warm glow of life there must be people
home
this seems like quite a lively community
you would think but I see walk closer
you come across a large locked gate and
assign warning ghosts trespassers you
start to realize that not all is as seen
and there is in fact something odd and
rather eerie about this estranged
settlement it's completely empty KITT
salt is a ghost town it's hundreds of
homes shopping malls sports hall and
shops are all completely deserted
yes the lights are still on power still
runs to the town homes are lit and
tables offset just as if the entire town
often left at a moment's notice because
that is exactly what's happened
KITT salt was built in 1979 to house the
families that worked as a nearby
molybdenum mine molybdenum is a metal
that was in very high demand by
manufacturing industries and Kittel was
a promising new start for many people
offering a well-paid job at the nearby
mine and the beautiful new community
built at a cost of 43 million dollars to
live amongst KITT sought was home to
1,200 residents and offered a hospital
Sports Center shopping mall restaurants
theatres grocery store library and of
course the local poor life was perfect
until one day just 18 months after the
town had been built the price of
molybdenum
first and the mine was shut down for
good
depriving over a thousand people of a
job with no reason left to continue to
support the town financially the owners
of Kissel evicted everyone pretty much
overnight the entire town's residents
were forced to leave their lives behind
and move never to return but many
residents left lights on at home and in
public buildings and the power to the
town was never turned off the owner also
paid to the entire town to be cleaned
and maintained every year to maintain
its appeal to potential buyers so for
over 30 years
kit salt has stood frozen in time life
looks the very same as the date was
evacuated electricity and all there's
just one thing missing the people but
the owners plan works because in 2004
the entire town was sold to an Indian
American businessman for 5.7 million
dollars he initially claimed that he was
going to refurbish the entire town and
turn it into a paradise community for
highly intellectual individuals where
they could collaborate on inventive new
projects and push the boundaries of
science amongst a stunning scenery the
entire town will be refurbished out of
his own pocket and he wouldn't seek to
make any profit from it what
unfortunately that turned out to be a
complete lie it was recently announced
that kid salt is being turned into a
liquefied natural gas plan to export
highly valuable unprofitable natural gas
the whole intellectual retreat thing was
just a big cover story so what's the
lesson here
if a stranger approaches you offering to
buy your abandoned mining town do you
best be sure of their intentions first
if you happen to be passing through
Bogota in Colombia and dare to venture
20 miles south on the unforgiving
wilderness near the spectacular taken
down the falls you will see an old
imposing building the carry asleep urged
on a cliff edge welcome to Hotel del
salto built in 1923 by an architect its
goal with 2 a try
wealthy tourists what pollution from the
Bogota River took hold and began to
quickly eat away in a road the
foundations of the building it was
quickly deemed too unsafe to continue
hosting guests and in the early 90s it
was completely abandoned it has sucked
their rotting ever since but this old
ruin has a twisted agenda during its
operational days as a world-class hotel
for the upper echelon of society the
hotel was the location of many three
suicides there is a local legend that
the indigenous peoples used to jump from
taken Deema fall to avoid being captured
by the Spanish conquerors according to
the legend the natives would transform
into an eagle halfway down the falls and
fly away to safely hotel guests must
have taken this legend a little too
seriously
because throughout the years many such
guests have grown themselves off the
cliffs and of the hotel's various
balconies suddenly for them they didn't
turn into eagles
the hotel was also reported to be
haunted by several tabloid newspapers
but that's hardly to driving I mean look
at the place this melancholy story
houses a somewhat happy ending them in
2011 the National University of Colombia
restored the building to its former
glory and made it into a museum for the
public called Tekken DeMuth Falls Museum
of biodiversity and culture celebrating
the national heritage and environment of
Colombia now a mine closing down and
haunted hotels is one thing but what
could cause an entire town of 1500
people in India to disappear in the
middle of the night
deep within the great Indian desert lies
a once thriving community called caldera
this medium-sized village has driven
historians and the Indian community
crazy for over 200 years because these
mysterious ruins hold a dark secret
not so far nobody has been able to
explain kadar was first settled in the
13th century by the pioneering power
well people from the nearby city of Pali
the population group and by the 19th
century there are over 1,500 residents
in caldera mostly farmers bankers and
agricultural traders the pally well
people were known for being business
minded and the village was prosperous
until one fateful night in 1825 the
village was suddenly deserted in the
middle of the night the entirety of the
settlement residents abandon their homes
and disappeared into the darkness sure
many settlements have been abandoned
throughout history due to play famine
drought and other natural disasters but
most are abandoned slowly over time
what's so eerie about caldera is that
every single residents left all together
at the same time and furthermore in the
dead of the night as if they were hiding
from someone or something to add more
fuel to this bizarre fire there were no
reports of 1,500 plus people looking for
refuge in nearby towns and cities the
following day or the following week or
the following month for that matter
nobody actually saw them leave the
village and nobody has found any trace
of where they went they simply
disappeared never to be seen again to
this day nobody knows what happened that
night it called on to cause the
disappearance of so many people but
local legends claim that before they
left the pali wells imposed a curse upon
the village that anyone who stepped foot
in it would experience paranormal
activity and death so that nobody could
ever react you pay it again
I'm not the village has gained a
reputation in Rajasthan for being
haunted in 2010 guru after re a
paranormal investigator from the Indian
Paranormal Society along with his team
of 12 other people spent a night in the
abandoned village
they claim to have heard creepy voices
and screams and even seen talking
spirits incidentally Tiwari died under
mysterious circumstances at his home
only a few years after visiting Waldo
some have said that this village was
deserted in the dead of the night due to
some evil paranormal force but some
historians claim a powerful local tyrant
called Salim Singh fell in love the
daughter of the villages chief Singh
gave the villages and ultimatum of two
days for the Chiefs daughter to marry
him or he would massively raise taxes on
the villages residents that would
economically [ __ ] the community and
so they fled in the middle of the night
out of fear and to avoid further
persecution by the unforgiving Singh
there are many such theories as to what
happened to caldera but to this day
none has been improved thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video then
please click here to support me on
patreon which helps out the channel and
you can get some cool rewards like early
access to all my videos click here to
watch another video and if you haven't
already don't forget to subscribe